oh I love this I've got to get on this  headline so many people underestimating  how scary it may get in the next three  to six months with the macro economy  this is absolutely the time to be  thoughtful thoughtful about a big  purchase houses cars renovations if  you're not sitting with a [ __ ] load of  savings don't get crazy now this is not  the time to [ __ ] Flex be thoughtful  be smart and then forget about big  purchases small purchases that add up  Ubers expensive coffees  seven streaming services when you only  use two get thoughtful look at that  credit card statement and see how many  things you're paying for each month that  you haven't canceled yet start getting  smart because it's hairy out there